good morning everyone
is everyone awake oh good morning
excellent so to get the energy up this
morning I think we should all just give
a big round of applause for the best
conference in the world excellent
alright so we're gonna talk about a sink
and a weight and getting back to the
basics do you all have JavaScript I'm
kidding we're gonna talk about c-sharp
someone left
hey I'm joking all right so we're gonna
talk about being efficient with async
annoyed and the word efficiency can mean
a few different things depending on who
you talk to
for me when I talk about being efficient
with a sink in a way it's about being
able to efficiently add code in my
applications and make the code readable
as well as maintainable for the future
and I also want to make sure that my
applications are understandable by my
users and that I don't have applications
that randomly crash because I have
threading issues and so forth so in this
case here efficiency means that we want
to make sure that we applied the async
and avoid keywords in a manner that make
sure that our applications work properly
and that it's easy for us to work with
them in the future
so why do we want to bother adding async
and a weight and the asynchronous
principles in our applications well
mostly it ends up being because near
api's that are out there we grab
packages when you get or we use more
discs or we use database calls and so
forth in our applications these new
api's are all asynchronous which means
that we will need to learn how to use
these principles properly and one really
big reason is because often this happens
we get an unreliable application and we
really want to avoid that now this is an
Android application and I'm not saying
that each Android application is
unreliable although by default the era's
itself is kind of although in this case
here this is a salmon application it's
using a c-sharp and everything that I'm
going to talk about here today is kind
of applicable in samory nor WPF or wing
forms or asp.net or console applications
any type of dark net application where
it differs between the different
applications I'll mention that for
instance in asp.net there are a few
things that are a little bit different
but most of the things that I'm going to
talk about is the same across all the
different types of dotnet up
so we want to increase this as
synchron's principles to avoid these
unreliable types of applications as well
as improving the user experience so how
do we avoid locking up the UI
well we leverage all the available
resources on our devices so this is my
superfast computer and it has a lot of
course a lot of memory a lot of disk and
if I use the asynchronous API is
properly I can leverage all of these
different resources but using this CPU
is not only about its synchro's
principles when we talked about CPU
bound operations we talked about
parallel programming so when we talk
about these asuma's principles a lot of
this is very similar to when we talk
about parallel programming these two
paradigms are very similar there's a
very thin line between what parallel
programming is and what a synchronous
programming is the fundamental
difference is that when we apply
asynchronous principles or asynchronous
programming when we start off a
concurrent operation the idea is that we
want to know when this thing is done so
for instance I go ahead and fetch some
data from the web I want to do that
somewhere else I'm gonna relieve my UI
of work so the user can do other things
in their applications and when the
data's been loaded from the web I want
to be notified and subscribe to that
event and be able to process that data
accordingly when we talk about parallel
programming we have a chunk of data we
want to process that by chucking that up
into smaller pieces and working with
them concurrently and we can apply these
different principles together as well so
here's an example of a mobile
application I click a button in the
mobile app it goes ahead and fetch you
some data when the data is downloaded it
can go ahead and process that in
parallel right so just to look at a
little bit of code it's gonna get ahead
of ourselves but this thing here starts
off in a synchronous operation it then
inside this is synchronous operation
does some parallel computing so you
might ask yourself why would you do this
because the the parallel extensions
using parallel for for instance that
locks up the current thread that you're
calling it on and this thing here now
all floats this work to another thread
in my application and don't worry we're
going to go through a little bit of this
throughout the talk so in order for us
to achieve this we need to go from a
approach to an asynchronous approach and
the way that we do that is by also going
from a blocking application like we saw
on the Android application that's
currently crashing or we're doing too
much work on the UI thread or the main
threading the application we're gonna be
notified that the always thinks that
this application has crashed so we want
to avoid blocking things and go to a
non-blocking application and
non-blocking code and the way that we do
that is by avoiding the heavy work on
the UI thread can it makes a lot of
sense but we don't really want to think
about the threads and managing the
threads thread cools ourselves so we
have helpers to allow us to work with
this more easily one thing that I will
mention here as well is that when we
work with the synchronous principles one
of the things that we should never do is
block our asynchronous operations so if
we for instance use an asynchronous API
loading something from disk or talking
to an web called using the HTTP client
we should never be calling the dot
result property or the dot weight method
because what happens then is that's
going to block their synchro's call and
in some cases that's going to end up
deadlock in your application you might
think that it makes your applications
application synchronous but what it's
really doing is that it's making your
application unreliable so in reality
what's going to happen here is that I'm
gonna take this Android application
we're gonna change this and apply some
asynchronous principles and all that we
are now left with it's a little bit of a
better user experience now if I show
this to the UX designers of my work it
are going to slap me in my face and say
that this is no better user experience
because I'm still blocking the
application but I argue that if I'm
faced with the the left picture here I
would most likely terminate the
application and tell the arrows to well
just terminate the app because I don't
think it's gonna respond
I think it's crushed well when I see the
the loading indicator I will be more
inclined to wait for that to finish so
how do we apply this in dotnet well we
use something called a task parallel
library which is the way first is
simplify working with both concurrent as
well as asynchronous code so even here
they line between parallel as well as
the sequence principles or a very thin
line so they group both of both of these
different paradigms together in the same
bucket so we can work with the
concurrent principles as well as the
Super's code and they're pretty much the
same thing the only difference instead
in a synchronous operation I can now
subscribe to whenever that's done so a
task allows us to represent one of those
things so we can represent work then we
want to do somewhere else so in this
case here I'm simply saying that I want
to run this thing somewhere else don't
block my current context don't block my
current thread just go ahead and run
this somewhere else manage the thread
for me I don't care if you're reusing a
thread in the thread pool or just do
this work somewhere else now what I can
do this task here is they're gonna I can
do a whole lot of different things I can
subscribe to whenever this is done I can
take care of a potential result if this
returns a value we have the task here
for instance for tasks of string it's a
generic class it will allow us to return
a value out of this as well
so I can use this to do a whole lot of
things and most of these synchronous API
is in.net is now leveraging this there
are other is synchronous ways and
principles and and patterns that we can
use as well but we're not going to cover
this here so let's just quickly have a
look at what this looks like the initial
studio I have an application I'm now
using WPF because it makes it easier to
run the application it's a little bit
faster than booting the Android emulator
so this is a simple just WPF application
I have a a couple of buttons over one
button I have a text block that allows
me to just enter some data in the UI
pretty simple and again this would be
the same in asp.net or in console
applications all these principles are
pretty much the same everywhere so now
what I'm doing here I'm clicking my
button and then what's happening here is
that we now have this test and run here
which is now offloading some work of a
method somewhere else so you'll see here
that I'm not using the anonymous method
that you saw in my slide I can also just
pass the the method name of whatever
method I want to run somewhere else I
don't have to care about scheduling this
on the thread pool and managing this
thread myself so what's happening here
is that this is going to run somewhere
else it's going to going to run on a
different context than the UI thread
which means that invoking the UI thread
if you've already done you are
programming this issue of hands how many
of you are done you are programming so
almost everyone in here has done
anything with UI programming you know
that if you're spawning off a threading
you trying to communicate back to the UI
thread you can have a problem because
you can
you cross threading when you're talking
back to the UI so everything in do
something here is going to have to
somehow communicate back to the UI
thread but you won't just be able to to
call it straight away so this here will
in fact crash work will give us an
exception right so we're trying to in
here update our text box inside the
application so this here should crash
the application but if we run the
application something interesting is
going to happen here so when I click the
button now you would probably expect
this to to crash I click run here in
fact nothing happens it dipped possibly
run this method here because I cannot
access at a breakpoint in here and we
can rerun the application and hopefully
now we can see here that we were inside
do you do something we respond off to a
different thread but nothing happened
didn't update the UI we didn't get an
exception the reason for this is if we
release the the debugger here now it's
going to tell us that we do have an
exception but it didn't crash the
application what's happening here is
that it's capturing this exception on
the task it is now now setting that on
the task itself so since we have this
task ID run here all the work we'll do
something is happening inside this other
task so whenever there's an exception on
this asynchronous operation is going to
capture that and set this on this state
of our task itself so now you might ask
yourself well how do we check that well
on the task itself we have a lot of
different properties we can check if we
have a fault state we can grab two
different exceptions that occurred on
this particular asynchronous operation
we can check if it's completed or
canceled and so forth but if I were to
check here if it's faulted right at this
point here the operation might not even
be done so the way that we make sure
that we can check if the task faulted it
or if it's completed and handled a
potential result is by introducing
something called a continuation now the
continuation allows us to kind of
subscribe to whenever a asynchronous
operation is done so a Munich's using
this method called continue with which
will be executed when our task is
completed
again I'm passing the method that I want
to run here I could use an anonymous
method as well if I want to do that and
what you'll see here in the method
signature is that
automatically going to pass the task
that completed and do something returns
a string which means that this thing
here will be returning a task of string
because it'll then return this string to
whoever's subscribing to the completion
so now in here we get the completed task
pass to handle test method we can here
check if it's if it's faulted or not so
if it's a breakpoint here we'll run this
here we'll see that we're gonna get an
exception we are now inside the
continuation and we can see that we have
this this faulted state on our task so
let me zoom in here a little bit too
much and you can see here that we have a
state is faulted and if we check the
exception here we can see that we have
the exception telling us that you cannot
do cross threading communication now
what's even more interesting is that we
know that we got in here and that it's
now trying to update our UI again the
problem here is that the continuation
using the task parallel library also
executes on a different context which
means that I'm not back at the UI thread
when I'm in the continuation here this
means that I'm trying to update the UI
but nothing happens so what happens with
this exception the thing is that when
you're inside a continuation that is
also wrapped in a new task so what we
have to do if you want to capture that
is to say well I want to continue with
with this thing and check if the the
task that I got here failed as well and
if that task fails this kind of gets
ugly right yeah so we don't want to do
that there's all these up to the
awesomeness of async in a way but then
you can see here that I'm using
something that told you to not never use
right so I told you to never use the
result property on your tasks that's
actually false you can use the result
property as long as you've properly
awaited your task right so inside here
we're inside the continuation what
happens here is that I can now grab the
result out of my tasks that just
completed so this here will give me the
the string representation of whatever
was returned so this here is going to
tell us from Phillip in the completed
task result here but how do we make this
work just to to show you that the demo
works it
order for us to update the UI we need to
cross communicate with a different
thread this works a little bit different
depending on the type of application
you're building but WPF we can use
something called a dispatcher I can
evoke something on the UI so I can
update the text here and let's just do
I've been doing coughing for a while
aware you don't need semicolons that's
nice
and then we'll do the same thing in our
narrate continuation and now this here
should hopefully work if we run this
it's gonna say hello for men do you see
in that form Phillip but this kind of
defeats the purpose of having
asynchronous code here right because now
what's happening here is the only thing
that we were really doing inside our
asynchronous operation that we're
offloading to somewhere else is
communicating back to the UI thread so
you will really have to be careful about
these different scenarios and where you
want to come back to the original
context and again this code starts to
look a little bit ugly I really don't
like when you have to use the dispatcher
I'd much rather have a more in a linear
way of reading my code and this here
becomes a little bit unmaintainable and
just to give you a little bit of a hint
of what happens now if I were to say
give me the result out of this here this
would now deadlock the application we'll
get into that a little bit later all
right so that kind of shows you how to
use the tasks in the TPL just the
fundamentals of how we work with these
with these different things now let's
talk about the async and away keywords
and how they we're going to improve the
ways that we work with this asynchronous
code in our applications because it's
going to be very different from using
the TPL I give this a raw way that we
just saw here so the async Inoue
keywords are simply contextual keywords
that means that when they announce the
async and away keywords being added in
language they didn't want to do any
runtime updates I do reckon that if they
were to add the async a network keywords
now like if you just imagine that we
didn't have the async in our keywords
they would probably release that with
dotnet core 4 or whatever and or docked
at 5 which is going to be the next thing
and they would probably update the
runtime to support co-routines
do it properly so what they've done here
with the contextual keywords is that
they've done a lot of compiler magic to
make this work so everything compiles
down to the the code that we have
available prior to the using the async
anyway keywords they're just building a
lot of things for us when we are
applying these things so when you're out
of the async in a wiki where it's what's
really happening is that it's generating
a lot of code and a lot of complexity so
the async and a weak keywords the idea
here is that we want to hide the
complexity that we just saw here so we
don't want to have this chain of
continuations and doing continue with we
want to make sure that if we get an
exception that's going to be traveled
back to whoever calls to asynchronous
method or whoever's awaiting that we
want to increase the readability because
in this case here if we had a problem in
our continuation we would have to put on
a new continuation and continue to do
with that and that quickly becomes very
ugly although the problem with async in
a way it is that it becomes more
error-prone so if we're applying these
keywords in the applications our
applications were the most definitely at
one point deadlock or crash or you'll
have a problem but let's try and see if
we can figure out why that would be so
this case here we have our very simple
simple method here and that pretty much
does nothing at all but I'm apply the
asing keyword and you can see here that
it's not returning anything right so
it's not returning a task by itself but
when we apply this async keyword what's
magically going to happen is that this
here it's going to generate some code
that will return a task for us right
that is so we can track the ongoing
operation in the ongoing works that
happening in here another thing to to
point out here is that we have the awake
keyword and if you ever see this being
used alone you're doing it wrong
you always want to use the async and
avoid keywords together and you only
want to use the await keyword whenever
there's something after it if the last
thing you're doing in your method is the
awake keyword and you don't have any
weights before that you can simply
return you can simply return the task
instead of avoiding it let's look at an
example of that later on so the awake
keyword it's now what we're going to use
in order for us to mark a continuation
so that means that we can replace our
continue with call with the awake
keyword as long as we mark the
methodists async we can now do this
instead what the way keyword will then
is that it'll validate the success or
failure of a task which means that it
will check for an exceptions it will
check that it's a successful motor
completed state it will make sure that
we come back to that particular context
whenever it's completed right but what's
interesting is that whenever it sees
their weight keyword it's going to
return back to whoever's calling our
method that means that it's not gonna
process any of the code in the
continuation which is after the away
keyword until after it's completed so
what's the big difference between a
weight and task can we continue with if
we just look at them like this here it
doesn't look like they're much different
but the thing is with the continuation
only continue with method we're on a
different context we're running on a
different thread so it will be very hard
for us to invoke the UI for instance or
talk back to the main thread or use
things from the original context right
if your thread static things that'll be
a little bit problematic as well so when
we're inside the continuation with the
avoid keyword we were back at the
original context and that'll make a lot
more sense when we we're gonna look at a
little bit about on the code that's
generated from this as well and when we
do it'll make a lot more sense why this
is being executed back on the original
context and why it's returning it tasks
and so forth but just keep in mind that
the idea here is that we're going to be
back versus a UI thread in this case
here so let's jump back into visual
studio and see how we can apply this in
our application so I have some some code
here I'm going to comment it out the e
the first portion of what I showed here
and we have pretty much the same thing
but it's now using the async and Away
keywords so we still have this method
called do something do something which
is up here it's a little bit different
now we were actually doing some work so
it's it's doing this task deal I 2000
which is simply a way for us to
represent that we're doing an operation
that takes a little bit of time instead
of me having to rely on the internet
connection in Australia to go and fetch
something from the web
I'd much rather fake the two seconds
happening here otherwise we'll be
waiting all day all right so now
mark this as a sink and we got the away
keyword these are all the C's together
right and then we're doing something in
the continuation so as long as do
something here it's being called from
the UI thread what's gonna happen here
is that the the last line which is
debugger text it's plus equal to hello
NDC it's going to be executed on that
same context so if I will look at how
this is being executed we have this run
click event handler the first thing that
we're doing is that we were updating our
text to starting then we're calling the
method do something this is all called
on on the same thread right we're
getting to the top thing here
it runs this line here and sees that
well there's a weight keyword here
so what's gonna happen now is that it's
going to return from the method it'll
return up here to the next line it's
gonna stay running and then we have the
awake keyword again and what's gonna
happen then it's gonna return back to
whoever's calling the click event Taylor
all right so then it'll return back and
then when it's done it's going to run
the continuations right so this here
says that well if this task is not
completed don't proceed executing the
things down here which is inside the
continuation of this method right only
executes this as long as our task here
executed properly and without any
exceptions so now what's gonna happen
here is that after about two seconds
we're going to be back inside our
context here to execute the continuation
and which is the first continuation well
it's the thing that we have here right
so this is the first continuation this
is our first awake keyword so this means
that the first thing that's going to
happen then it's going to execute hello
NDC then it's going to find out that
well now that task is done so we can go
ahead and run the continuation of this
task gonna be down here and so first
let's just run the application have a
look so it should say starting running
hello in DC and then whatever comes next
year and what's interesting here as well
is that you can see here
note this doesn't build that's great
because the app is running
starting running hello in DC uh please
yeah there we go and then it's going to
go ahead and run whatever's after here
so now what's interesting here is that
out of do something we grab the tasks we
can start this operation we can run some
more code and then we can say well I
want to wait that and run all the code
after this here whenever that task is
done so then it proceeds to call the
same pretty much the same handle task
function that we had earlier it can
check if the task is faulted or not so
if ever had an exception which we didn't
so it didn't do anything
let it go ahead and run something else
that's asynchronous so you see that we
can have multiple awake keywords in the
same method no problem the thing here is
that this one here isn't executed until
you know we're back in the continuation
of the first one so do something more
here also sleeps for two seconds right
so that that's going to be executed
after after the first continuation is
done does that make sense so how do we
now know that the tasks failed or
preceded properly well I mentioned that
if we throw an exception in here we
can't get an exception out of cross
threading now right because we're now
back at the UI thread here at the bottom
so that just works but if I throw an
exception after two seconds I can spell
throw throw hello
does anyone want to come up here and
help me write some code there we go so
now if I run this here this should
probably crash up to two seconds and now
the application crashes so that's pretty
good the exception that we got earlier
or the exception that we get now is now
traveling back to whoever's calling this
method so how do we make sure that the
application doesn't crash well first of
all we don't throw in exceptions but
after that we make sure that we wrap
things in a try and catch block so now I
can go ahead and try and catch this
and now if we put a breakpoint here and
run this we'll see that we caught the
exception of the task so what happened
here is that not only does it travel
back to whoever's calling the method we
call in context it also makes sure that
the task completed properly and we can
catch those exceptions as well so that's
all great this allows us to write a
little bit more readable code I would
aren't you know to do not have so much
coding your handlers or whatever but you
want to make sure that you always have
the async and awake keywords together
and I never ever want to see async void
used in your applications and we'll get
into that in just a moment and see how
how really terrible that is but pretty
much if you use that in a car you'll die
all right perfect
so this here narrow illustrates that we
can do the synchronous operations that
we saw earlier we can await the tasks
and we can make sure that we're back at
the original context but what's also
interesting here is that what if this
thing here were to spawn off a different
task so let's say that this let's get
rid of the exception first let's say
that this task itself returns something
or it returns a task that runs something
you could have a task that spawns
another task how do we how do we make
that work well we could for instance say
that we have a task of a task and we
could flow let's do it in the other
method instead we could say down here
instead so instead of returning the
string here we can say that we return a
task of a task of a string or whatever
you want to do that but like one two and
what I can do here is that I can now say
I want you to create a task in this case
here we have a static story that I want
to return but the signature of my method
tells me that I have to use a task of
tasks of strings so now I can represent
a completed task with a particular
result I could also say that we have a
task of from exception or from what they
don't have those here but you can't
create tasks from exceptions and I think
that depends on the dotnet version but
now what happens here is how do we
you make sure that this how do we await
that the thing here this here do
something more is now going to return a
task of task right so we can simply
apply our keyword in front of that way
keyword and now the code is so much more
readable and so much more understandable
it's still gonna do the same thing
hopefully hopefully still gonna work
there we go still works so no matter if
if we imagine doing this with the the
TPL would have to have a continuation
and then the continuation inside of that
and it would just look very nasty but
now this thing here takes care of first
it's checking where all of us happening
here is that if we do this a little more
readable what's gonna happen here is
that the first thing ever get we get the
task which is running a task itself
right it's grabbing that task it's
validating that that task executed
properly and then when that task returns
its task
it's then validating that there's no
exceptions so that's pretty helpful all
right everything's clear so far it's
totally understandable it will never
have any dead locks I promise so let's
talk about the state machine this is the
thing that's returned or the the thing
that's generated whenever we apply the
async keyword so the state machine is
pretty much this thing like a nagging
kid in the back of your car that's
asking if you're there yet it's just
continually asking if you if the
synchronous operation is done if it's
not done
it'll proceed doing other things if it's
done it's going to execute the
continuation now my daughter is only two
years old she's telling me that we're
there she's not asking she says telling
me to stop the car so now what else does
the state machine do well it handles the
result of the potential errors that
means that if there's a result on our
synchronous operations it'll make sure
that that travels back to wherever you
want to set that it also makes sure that
if there's an exception it's going to
put that on whatever thing that's
awaiting it right so if we have an
exception in on a task that's have a
continuation on the UI thread and throw
the exception back on the UI thread and
you can you can pretty much just handle
that properly right so it's also in
charge of executing the code after the
away keyword so that's great so what
does the ACE
sinky weren't really do well it's
generating the state machine and what
it's doing this it's moving the entire
method body into a different thing
sounds good right
so precompilation our method looks
fairly simple we're having some variable
English civilizations we do an
asynchronous operation and then we were
running something to debug the pipeline
well this is compiled the code looks
nothing like what we had earlier there's
no debug dot write line here there's no
variable initialization everything's
moved into this generated state machine
here but now you can see here why the
method signature it just removed the
async keyword and the the reason that it
doesn't keep the async e-word when it's
compiled is because the IL the the
language that's the the runtime executes
doesn't have any any async keywords or
anything like that so what's what it's
doing here it's using just some compiler
magic to generate code that's doing all
of this for us it generates the state
machine and runs all of these different
things
and it's returning a task with any
representation of the ongoing work so we
can keep track off of their works that
happening if there's a new results if
there's any exceptions and so forth and
then if we peek inside the state machine
now the implementation is really that
important but it's interesting to see
that inside the state machine we have
our test a delay here it's getting here
waiter the thing that it that keeps
track of if that particular task is done
and then it can check if that is
completed or not if it's not completed
its gonna return to whoever calls this
thing inside the state machine in the
state machine then execute these things
again and check if it's done and so
forth then at the bottom here we're back
and running everything in the
continuation so now this kind of makes
sense right if you go back and have a
look at this post compiled code here you
can see that everything here is executed
on the same thread right everything here
every line here is executed on it on the
UI thread for instance there's nothing
here going off running some something
somewhere else that means that the code
that we have in here if you look at the
last line here that is executed on the
UI thread as well so that's executed in
the same context all right just keep
that in mind for now and we'll talk a
little bit about async board this is a
picture of me whenever I see async
forward and
applications is it really that bad well
obviously otherwise I'm gonna talk about
it so acing forward in this case here it
doesn't look like it's that bad what's
happening here is that we have the same
method signature all that it did was
remove the tasks here and replace that
would void so what's the big issue here
well first of all if we look at the
generated code here there's nothing
returned from the method which kind of
makes sense because it's Markus Boyd
although a task that doesn't represent
or doesn't tell you that it's returning
a value it's a task that's by definition
not returning anything and that's a void
task whatever you want to call it but in
this case here we're actually using void
itself so we have no way of tracking the
ongoing operation we have no way of
knowing if there was an exception so
that's why I why I said earlier that it
whenever you see a car running c-sharp
and using a Seng void I would change car
I won't use this one so how do we fix
this well it's pretty simple right we
just swap it out with tasks that very
very very subtle okay there we go
freshly I'm so all right so if we just
replace this with the task here we kind
of changed the the signature of our of
our method in our application right this
here now changes the contract of whoever
is calling this method which means that
if there was a potential error here
before I've worked with developers that
like to get exceptions thrown back to
the UI and crash the application rather
than gracefully just capturing all of
them personally I don't like that as a
user so please never do that just in
this case here if we get an exception
here this will tear down the application
in this case here we wouldn't know if
there was an exception or not if we
don't await this thing here so how about
we just have a look at on an ASIC void
demo it's always fun to look at crashing
applications so I have this thing here
it's a simple method and it's doing a
net weight task to delay doing some
asynchronous operation and then I'm just
throwing it out throwing an exception
this here is marked as a Seng void a
should never do that but where would it
put this exception so if I simply call
this method I'm gonna call it up here
run async I can't apply the my keyword
here right because I don't have a time
this doesn't return anything so this
will not tell me well this is a symboi
door this is not returning a task so you
can't await this that's a little bit
problematic so now if I run the
application not only can I not say that
all of these things down here I can't
move them into a continuation of run a
sync they will have to be executed
sequentially right so if I click run
here after you're about two seconds I
think the application is going to crash
and it looks like it did crash right so
that's not good so how do we solve this
again obviously don't throw any
exceptions but if we have to how about
we just wrapped it in a try-catch block
can I see a show of hands how many of
you think this is going to work what's
kind of leading question right the same
thing here I run the application after
for two seconds the application is going
to crash even though I'm wrapping this
thing here in a Tron cache block what's
happening here is run async is being
executed on the UI thread it's not being
executed in line here so it knows
nothing about the trying catch block so
this thing here wouldn't be able to
capture that exception so what really
happens here is that whatever this
exception in run async occurs it's going
to set that back to whoever's calling
the method or the call in context or the
app domain or whatever you want to call
it this means that it's going to tear
down the application because this here
is being executed on the UI thread and
so forth so that's not really good so
the way that we saw this of course is by
changing this to a task instead but then
we have to properly avoid this in order
for us to capture the exception and now
what happened is that the code down here
won't be executed until two seconds
after so in a changing behavior of the
application which we might not have
wanted to and to keep that in mind so we
don't we want to avoid async void but if
we simply replace it with async tasks
instead we might have different
implications in the application all
right so let's talk about a little bit
more fun things let's talk about
deadlocking how many of you experience a
deadlock excellent
that's perfect so almost all of you have
had a padlock and those of you that
didn't raise your hand I know you've had
a bit look you just don't know yet so
real a deadlock is we've we've seen that
problems can occur and when we had a
deadlock in the applications it pretty
much means that there's no point of
return we can't return from a deadlock
so a pretty hard to read example of that
is is this here so let's say that we are
running some asynchronous operation this
year just delays for one millisecond
which isn't really that long inside the
continuation of this method or inside
the continuation here I want to invoke
the UI like we saw earlier I want to
update the UI whenever I'm done inside
the continuation like we do with the a
white keyword so why shouldn't I be able
to do that here but then when I say here
I really want this to to block my
application I don't want this to to go
ahead and be asynchronous I want my
users to suffer so what happens if we do
this here this here is now going to say
that I want to block this thread from
executing anything else until there's a
synchronous operation is done however
what's happening here is that we have an
asynchronous operation that needs to
talk to the UI thread and the UI thread
is being blocked hence we have a
deadlock all right looks like a complex
scenario it looks like something none of
us would do in our applications right
although what's interesting here is that
there's an easier way to get a deadlock
and that's just simply to call wait on
an asynchronous method right and I see
this happening quite often not
particularly using the wait key the wait
method but you think the results
properly for instance especially if
you're writing unit tests or you might
not have asynchronous is the async
Android keyword available inside your
test Runner and so forth you might be
calling the dot result and that just
deadlocks the test so that's not good
so let's avoid doing that all right and
then another thing I see quite often is
the the unnecessary use of a lot of
different state machines so I mentioned
earlier that if you're not doing
anything anything inside your
continuations there's no point in having
the away keyword so an example of that
is where this run async method and you
know naming things is hard so that's why
- next method is one internal async and
so forth right so I have all of these
different methods and
one of the common things there is that I
have the async and away keywords because
one of the misconceptions when using
async and awaitin using the task Perl
library he said wherever you had to have
a task you need to await that because
someone once said that you should use
async and await all the way down and
that means the flying day sink & Away
keyword everywhere where you see a task
but that's not really what that means it
means that we shouldn't be blocking our
synchronous operations we shouldn't use
the result property we shouldn't use the
wait keyword the wait method but we
shouldn't do this either because this is
really inefficient and if we want to be
efficient with a sink and a weight and
write readable and maintainable code
this is not really what we want you
because what's gonna happen here is that
we're gonna generate a state machine
here a generate a state machine here
here and here as well and then we don't
do anything in the continuation here so
there's no point in having those async
you know what keywords so if there's
nothing in the continuation there's no
need for an away keyword so the way that
we kind of sold this it's by simply
replacing the await keyword with a
return and then removing the async
keyword and we have the same method
signature but less code that's being
generated all right so let's have a look
in Visual Studio what that looks like so
the console application and since C
sharp seven point two or three you can
now have asynchronous main methods which
is really nice I don't know if any one
rule of rights console apps though
outside of demos so this running Sigma
third here all of these different
methods that we just saw here they're
all appending the async and avoid
keywords even though they might not need
to if there's nothing here below this
keyword there's no need for the away
keyword although the the case of this
being like this here we do have
something in the in the continuation
right so in this case here we have two
synchros operations being scheduled and
we are awaiting both of them but if all
that you want to do is wait for both of
these to finish and you don't care about
them being executed at the same time do
you know what we can do instead we can
do task dot when all we can do the tasks
delay like this here
can get rid of this thing here do that
easy
start off to both synchronous operations
at once we have a task that represents
when both of these are done and now we
don't have the async in that way keyword
anymore so if I just go back here and
we'll have a look at what the code here
looks like when it's being generated I'm
gonna compile this here I'm gonna head
over to reflector which is an
application that will allow me to have a
look at the code that's being generated
so you'll you'll see here that we have a
lot of things inside our inside our
class here in particular we have these
different asynchronous state machines
that's now being generated so we have
one for run async one for running turtle
one for something using something
internal async and so forth and for this
like for this demo here there's not a
lot of code inside the state machine but
for simply returning in a senior's
operation which is to test delays this
is a lot of code right and if we have
more complex code or complex methods
this here could look a lot worse so of
course the simple way of solving this is
to just replace the replace the away
with your weight with return get rid of
the task and if we do the same thing
here you see the the signature of the
method and whoever's calling the method
is doing the same thing doesn't change
the behavior of the app doesn't really
change how you use the the methods and
now we got a little bit less code
generated so that's a nice improvement
to our application so that's the
unnecessary of state machines let's also
have a look at dead locking all right so
for dead locking I mentioned that it's
really easy for us to deadlock if we're
calling weight or result on one of our
synchronous operations and here I have a
little bit more of a a real-world
scenario I'm trying to read a file from
disk and then what I'm doing here is I'm
reading the file a synchronously from
start to end and then I'm going to set
the result on my
to do that so now what's interesting
there are two things that's interesting
here this new c-sharp age feature which
is enhanced using so we can we no longer
have to wrap the entire thing and I
using block and I have a talk on c-sharp
8:00 tomorrow if you want to come to
that now what's happening here is that
all of this code here is being executed
on our UI thread right so from top to
bottom it's all being executed on the UI
thread the continuation needs to
communicate back to the UI thread which
means that when we block the UI thread
like this here the state machine can no
longer execute and that's problematic
right so there's a way for us to solve
this now imagine that I really want to
block this this call here what I can do
is that I can I can wrap this in a new
task and say I want to run the state
machine somewhere else and I want this
to I want to wait for that what's
happening here now is I'm blocking the
UI thread
I'm taking my task and I'm running that
I'm taking the state machine and running
that on a separate thread do you think
this code is bug free now it's not
promise so what's happening here is that
were getting an exception right because
we're now trying to update our dy from a
different tack task right previously our
run async method tried to invoke the UI
because we expect it to be on the UI
thread in this continuation right so as
good developers do we're gonna increase
the dispatcher does anyone think this is
going to work this isn't gonna work
either because what we will now have a
deadlock again because now I'm trying to
update the UI in the continuation but
I'm blocking the UI until this entire
thing is done right
so trying to refactor the application
and make it better but we are just
making it worse still have a deadlock so
this kind of illustrates that it's super
easy for us to introduce deadlocks in
our applications so of course the the
proper way to solve this is to change
this here to a returning string we're
gonna return this thing here instead the
last thing here is the awake humored
right so we can probably that
and now we could probably do this
but remember I said never use some
result property so we would have to
introduce the async and it would cure it
to make this work a little bit more
nicely
one thing one thing to keep in mind I
mentioned earlier that we can remove the
async anyway keyword if there's nothing
in the continuation this thing here is a
continuation as well so whenever we were
assigning a variable or whenever we are
in this case invoking the UI after the
away keyword that's also something that
happens in the continuation so now the
application is going to behave a little
bit better although we had to do a
little bit of refactoring to make this
work properly and the contract of the
method now changed and our it was a lot
of work just to make this work right but
then again we don't have a deadlock
anymore
so one more thing I want to talk about
is cancellations this is one thing that
I see being misused quite often so we're
gonna look at an example that again
looks a little bit tedious but in this
case here I have this long-running
operation it's a wild fruit loop I want
to offload that to somewhere else I'm
gonna run this long-running operation
somewhere else even though this might be
more CPU bound I can use the TPL because
the TPL is always also used for
concurrent work right so what we're
doing here is we're simply trying to
update the UI every every 500
milliseconds and this task a deal I here
at the bottom just to illustrate some of
some work happening with that data now
I'm gonna run this here in a separate
task because this is son it's both on
asynchronous method because we have the
the async and away keywords right but
it's a while true loop and this thing
here is going to be executed on the UI
thread if we run this off our click
event handler so we don't want that so
I'm gonna wrap that in a new task to
offload the work of this entire while
true loop to somewhere else but we're
also going to pass something called a
cancellation token now when I do this
this will allow me to then cancel this
cancellation token when the cancellation
token source here which allows us to
signal all the tokens or all the places
that's using the token that you should
now cancel so pass this cancellation
token in here and then we can call
cancellation token but cancel I don't
see these very often although when you
call cancellation token source that
cancels nothing's going to happen so if
you were working with Coughlin for
instance if you if you just canceled
you're co-routines it'll just terminate
the entire thread which is in my opinion
a weird thing to do because if we do
something in here and there's a
cancellation scheduled we might want to
roll back the the newest change or the
newest thing that you did right
so just terminating the thread could be
that we're terminating whatever we are
trying to set debug duck text which
means that we might end up in a really
weird scenario in the application so how
do we make sure that we can listen for
whenever the task is cancelled we can
introduce this thing here since we have
the cancellation token we can now say if
there's a cancellation request I'd just
throw an exception and whoever is
listening to this asynchronous operation
if they're properly awaiting this they
will get an exception telling them that
this was canceled all right it's really
super simple and we can do this in in
different variations as well so if we
have a look at pretty much the same code
here but if we neglect to have the
cancellation too token telling us that
it's cancellation has been requested if
we just run this application it's pretty
much the same application that way
earlier and click run here and when I
click cancel here nothing's gonna happen
right and if I introduce this thing here
all that I'm doing inside my cancer
click event tailor is : cancel the
cancellation token source is being
updated to a new one every time I click
my run run method otherwise what's gonna
happen is that you were always going to
start this off with a canceled
cancellation token and if you call task
dot run with a canceled cancellation
token you won't start so that's kind of
bad so let's run the application again
I'm gonna click run here and then I'm
gonna cancel and you can see that there
was a slight delay there that I could
cancel and then it still entered one
last element so depending on when you
add the cancellation when you add the
eliciting for the cancellation token you
could have moved this up two to the top
up here or to the bottom kind of depends
on how you want to handle that you can
also listen for it to subscribe to
whenever a cancellation has been
requested so that's one way of doing it
but I also have a a WPF core application
so we're done of course we for now we
now use WPF which means that we can now
leverage the new c-sharp 8 features
which means that I can now use my async
restreams in this application so we'll
go through this demo as well it's a
little bit more of a real-world scenario
so this run click event tailor here it's
going to set my text to nothing at all
it's gonna create a new cancellation
token source it's gonna run my run async
method the run async method now has this
this new syntax for a for each loop
where I say for each element which is
going to come to me asynchronously
I want to await that so we have the away
keyword in front of the for each loop
because each element that I get out of
this lyrics thing here is going to be
streamed to the application makes a lot
of sense right hopefully it will when we
look at the implementation here so this
here is a new thing as well the ia
syncing numerable you can use the
normally and use async task or an async
task like object but in this case here
we have an i async enumerable of string
which means that we are going to return
one line at a time we're going to read a
line from disk we're going to do some
work with that and then we're going to
return that back to the caller so for
each line that we get it's going to be
streamed back to whoever's calling this
so that's pretty cool and now I want to
be able to cancel this as well so I have
the cancellation token in here so after
I read the line from disk I can't pass a
cancellation token to read line async
because it doesn't support the
cancellation so I have to do the
cancellation in my while loop here right
and again I have a cancel button so when
I click that hopefully it's going to
cancel the application so rickrolled I
can click cancel and the operation was
cancelled super simple
another scenario where you might want to
use this is something that I call smart
cancellations so I'm gonna run the
application first and then we'll talk
through the code that I have here so
imagine being able to search for
something so whenever I work with mobile
applications I try to apply this pattern
so I for instance I want to search for
I've been doing public transport so you
want to search for the closest stop or
you want to search for a bus that's
going to leave in 10 minutes when the
user enters the data you don't want to
API for every keystroke you want to
figure out how long does it take for a
user to type a word and then when they
stop typing you want to search for that
particular thing they're searching for
so we cannot make sure in four out of
milliseconds or 500 milliseconds so
whenever I type something in here you
can see that I'm going to have bort the
call to my thing and then after a little
while it's going to to go ahead and
query my my API or whatever so whenever
I write something here it's going to
cancel that so for every keystroke and
then when I stop typing it's going to
search and the way that we saw this is
by simply listening for whatever the
text changes whatever the text changes
I'm going to cancel the ongoing
operation so you might ask yourself what
is the current ongoing operation well I
have attached a dealer here for 500
milliseconds I'm gonna pass the
cancellation token in here so if I
simulate 500 milliseconds worth of work
and I don't cancel that I know that in
the continuation of these 500
milliseconds I can now go ahead and load
my data of the web or from wherever I
want to load that you might also want to
pass the cancellation token in here and
have that properly propagated down to
your HTTP clients or whatever but this
piece that I can now capture whenever
there's an exception because when I
await this here it's going to throw an
exception whatever this has been aborted
all right so that means that we are
going to be an exception handler down
here and we can now handle that properly
all right so let's look at one final
thing I haven't talked much about
asp.net but one of the things I do want
to mention everything that we've talked
about except the how do we invoke the UI
of course is different in asp.net
although one of the misconceptions maybe
not anymore about in the early days of
the async anyway key words was that when
you apply the async in a way keyword
like I'm doing here for instance on my
index action is that you would
automatically automatically get Ajax on
your client but that's not really the
case so what you get here is that the
server-side part is asynchronous which
means that if we are running some work
here that takes a long time we're load
something from discord the database the
web server can now go ahead and take
care of other requests while it's going
on that means that if we have the away
keyword here it's going to release the
thread back to the thread pool so that
IAS can take care of other requests in
asp.net other than that we can use the
async and avoid keywords just like we do
in WPF or console applications we can
even get the deadlock like we do in
other types of applications as well so
if I do the same thing here we have this
thread on the thread pool running our
application if I run this and call slash
home slash deadlock if I can spell home
this will in fact deadlock the
application so if we run but now if I
run this thing here it's gonna say okay
so it still listens for for other
requests wipe but we have a thread here
that's now deadlocked how it's going to
handle that afterwards I'm a little bit
unsure if it's go ever going to
terminate the threader or not but just
avoid deadlock in your applications and
you will probably be fine other than
that we can use to pretty much the same
principles in asp.net in earlier
versions of not core versions of asp.net
so you have a speed-up net the the
normal MVC and web api you use something
called the configure a waiter or
configure await in order for you to be
able to configure how you want the
continuation to to to work so for
instance here I could say configure
await and say false this means that
whenever you are done it's not going to
try Marshall back to the original
context which means that when we were
down here it's a completely different
thread or different context than what we
had up here that makes sense all the way
in asp.net core that works a little bit
different so I don't want to talk too
much about that because it's just gonna
be confusing but basically you can just
remove this in asp.net core but if
you're working with libraries you might
always want to do this because what
happens is that all the code here above
the or below the continuation is now not
going to try and get back to the
original context so if you're working
with libraries for
that don't care about the original
context or their original thread you
don't have to try and marshal back to
that one more thing about that is it
only affects this method in here so if
we have someone listening for this
method somewhere else let me show you
what I mean about that so if we have if
I do this configure right in in my run
async method that's not going to affect
this method up here right it only
affects this one and the things after
its continuation but again that's
totally confusing and if you're run into
problems with asp.net and asynchronous
programming hate me I hate to be up on
Twitter and I'll try to help you up for
that right so if you want a little bit
more I've recently redone my async async
course on Pluralsight so you can go
ahead and and check that out it goes
through all of these things in much more
detail I talk about parallel extensions
and a little bit more about how you can
use these two paradigms together and if
you do check it out let me know if you
if you like it or not right so to wrap
this up we've talked about everything
from the beginning of how you use two
tasks parallel library to how we apply
the async and avoid keywords and do that
in an efficient manner because
efficiency can mean that we are
efficient in writing the code and being
efficient in maintaining the code but
also reducing the amounts of generated
code and the potential problems in our
applications so I think that if we try
to apply a lot of these things in our
applications we will try we will
probably avoid some deadlocks and some
problems in the future so I hope you
enjoy this talk and that you got
something out of it if you have any
questions you can ping me on twitter i'm
philip Ekberg and it's been my pleasure
being back here in Sydney thank you so
much
[Applause]